here now with reaction is former
arkansas governor mike huckabee and
former senior senior adviser to
president trump stephen miller governor
let me start with you did
they believe what they were saying or
was it always just a cynical play
what they thought was donald trump's
weakness they would they would build
their campaign on knowing we'll figure
it out when we get there
pete i think the truth is they didn't
know what they were saying that's what
made it so bad
and joe biden really i think burped out
a little bit of truth the other day when
he didn't expect that he would be doing
it when he said there's no federal
solution
i don't think that's what he intended to
say but it's the truth and deep down he
knew it interestingly that's exactly
what donald trump said from the
beginning he said that we have to let
governors manage this crisis he
understood he respected the 10th
amendment joe biden didn't what i find
most interesting is that all of the
legal positions that the white house
under biden has taken have been because
he has the authority to set the policy
now he's admitted not only does he not
have the authority but he doesn't have a
clue how to fix what he claimed he would
have fixed long before now i think the
bi-administration and all their
attorneys need to go to the courts and
say
uh
forget about all that stuff that we
filed just go ahead and
mark it down we had no idea what we were
doing
stephen i remember the trump
administration being criticized
effectively the argument was well you're
passing the buck to the states so that
you don't have to take responsibility if
things go wrong
or was it different stephen a
recognition that a challenge of this
magnitude the china virus required
dynamic local solutions from people who
could actually make the decisions and
ultimately there's no way a federal
government in washington dc could could
it could apply mandates that are
effective in every place considering new
york city is a little different than
rural oklahoma was that part of the
calculation for the trump administration
well i had the privilege as you know
working for president trump when he
launched the greatest national
industrial mobilization since world war
ii when this pathogen landed on our
shores when it came to core issues of
civil rights and civil liberties he
respected local citizens local
governments and state governments but
when it came to putting together a
national response let's not forget this
was a completely new pathogen from
scratch president trump brought us tests
pcrs antigen tests rapid tests at home
tests he brought us a bevy of
therapeutics including monoclonal
antibodies had proven to be remarkably
effective he brought us three vaccines
from scratch and he brought mass brought
us ventilators brought us gloves brought
us medical gowns all of this all of this
from scratch joe biden inherited every
single one of those tools plus a year of
clinical data and what have we gotten
record death record cases that is an
inexcusable failure and this statement
now that he's helpless as president is
nothing more than a cry for help saying
that he is in over his head and has no
clue what he's doing
is this governor
the beginning of a backtrack is this the
beginning of staring at poll numbers
staring at
case rates not that that's the right
metric because it isn't but looking at a
new variant and new lockdowns that are
that are occurring in certain places are
they saying well we're just it's just
not working maybe the trump playbook
was more effective than ours
well it was more effective and that's
one of the things that we uh have seen
stephen miller was exactly right what he
said and if you remember what president
trump did
he made available all of the resources
and assets and said if you're a governor
then ask for the help and we will send
it to you but you'll manage it and so he
sent hospital ships to new york they
never needed them or used them but he
sent them because they said they needed
them he sent ventilators there more than
they needed but he made them available
that's how it's supposed to work the
governor's managed the crisis but the
federal government is an assistant to
help provide resources and assets what
joe biden came along and said was i'm
going to do it it's going to be fixed by
me and joe biden got in there and found
out that the people he was most critical
of people like ron desantis people like
greg abbott and others were actually
managing the crisis a heck of a lot
better than he was
and so i i don't think that he intended
to basically wave the white flag in that
press event yesterday with the governors
but that's exactly what he did
it sure looked like it and stephen
before i go to you real quick governor
uh if if you're a governor right now of
a free state or you take the mentality
of balancing actual freedom and and
livelihood vis-a-vis science whatever
that means by those who espouse it these
days what's the move of those governors
now that now that effectively biden has
said there is no federal response is
there more governors can do
well i think they're frustrated and
frustrated that they've spent a year
waiting on joe biden to give them
leadership that he never gave them and
of course some of them quite frankly are
probably very just bum-fuddled because
they thought the whole time was that
they were supposed to just wait and get
orders from washington but the effective
governors haven't waited they've taken
the crisis they've managed it and their
people are better off and they're more
free that's how it's supposed to work a
simple reading of the 10th amendment
would help validate that
stephen if you uh it's a hypothetical
but it's worth looking into a bit if you
were in the white house with donald
trump right now considering where we are
you know there probably would have been
a delta probably would have been omicron
who who knows but this omicron variant
is much different thank goodness it's
much less lethal at least we know that
we believe that to be true although more
highly transmissible
what approach do you think a trump
administration would be taking right now
or a reasonable administration would be
taking well i have no doubt as to what
president trump would have done if he
continued to occupy the oval office
first of all he would have continued to
push new therapeutics which would have
massively cut deaths massively cut
hospitalizations secondly he would have
never undermined confidence in the
vaccine the way that joe biden did
thirdly and again going back to governor
huckabee's point he would have made sure
states had the resources especially
testing where joe biden has bundled it
beyond imagination president trump would
never have used the cudgel of brutal
mandates especially on our children
these toddler mask mandates are insane
and depriving children of a crucial
development window and finally finally
on top of all of that he would have
worked in partnership with our governors
to craft local strategies that made
sense particularly with emphasis on
sheltering the highest risk individuals
not a broad based blunt approach
absolutely stephen thank you steve
governor hawkins stephen miller thank
you both very much tonight really
appreciate your insight this evening hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else